le problème de l'électricité on est
arrivé en fin de décembre on devait
avoir notre notre nouveau contrat
énergie puisque le gros souci c'est ceux
qui terminent le 31 décembre pour
négocier les tarifs aujourd'hui au 31
décembre c'est un touchable on va passer
de 7 centimes de kilowatts à 67 centimes
alors pour schématiser c'est multiplié
par 10 donc ça veut dire que tu payais
combien d'électricité 1200 € par mois
donc tu es passé à 12000 donc c'est
alors comment tu fais voilà c'est
impossible il faudrait qu'on sorte de
5000 euros de marche supplémentaires
avec toute la marchandise qui a augmenté
de 30%, les PGA remboursé les hausses
des salaires etc c'est même pas la peine
donc là aujourd'hui on ferme et on
attend de négocier un nouveau tarif on
nous dit peut-être qu'en janvier ça a
baissé mais on sait pas et donc la
janvier tu dis je préfère baiser puisque
tu vas perdre de l'argent ah oui oui
tout à fait toute façon ne peut pas
gagner c'est impossible c'est impossible
impossible là c'est très clair s'il n'y
a pas de bouclier tarifaire on va tous
crever Jean-Paul le terme crever c'est
ça voilà mais est-ce que ça bouge parce
que là je te dis on ne voit et on envoie
tous les jours chez vous aussi on voit
plein de un petit commerçants de
restaurants de boulangerie on arrive un
matin et puis on voit fermer terminer
c'est incroyable comment tu fais toi
donc là pendant un mois tu comment tu
fais mais pour l'instant on ferme on
attend des offres des des
messages ou à tous les fournisseurs
d'énergie faites-nous des bonnes offres
à ce qu'on va crever on va tous crever
c'est jeudi et je mets tout l'artisanat
parce qu'on parle des restaurateurs mais
on peut parler des boulangers tous les
artisans on est tous logés à la même
enseigne tous ceux qui dépassent 36
kilowatts aujourd'hui
ne sont pas dans le Bouclier tarifaire
et on va sur des x 10 x 20 moi j'ai des
gens des fois qui m'appelle je suis
président de mon syndicat lumi des gens
qui m'appellent cet après-midi ils me
disent Adrien on va fermer on va fermer
on a plus rien on va tout perdre et la
croyez-moi ils font s'approcher vraiment
parce qu'il faut être dur dans les fonds
dans sa tête c'est pour ça que j'ai le
gouvernement il y a pas de secret hein
monsieur monsieur Macron Monsieur le
Maire madame borne madame Grégoire
bougez-vous mettez ce bouclier tarifaire
sinon on est tous morts on va tous
mourir
chaque jour qui passe il y a des dégâts
tous les jours c'est des dépôts de bilan
qui vont arriver tous les jours tous les
jours tous les jours tous les jours
alors justement Stéphane géant d'un
restaurant Le carnet à Paris
depuis nombreuses semaines vous nous
l'avez dit vous sentiez la catastrophe
arrive moi on l'a senti il a anticipé un
peu plus que moi parce que on a vu les
trucs venir mais là là c'est une
catastrophe en fait moi j'ai des
prélever le 24 décembre on m'avait dit
que ça allait augmenter donc je m'y
attendais on parlait des boulangers
électricité ouais l'électricité donc je
m'attendais à une augmentation je me
suis dit des boulangers peut-être plus
que nous parce qu'ils ont peut-être plus
de fourche bon et je m'attendais pas à
ça en fait j'ai été prélevé le 24
décembre de 10000 euros et ensuite une
semaine après j'ai reçu un mail en me
disant que ma prochaine facture le 11
janvier allait être de 19000 euros
19000 € en sachant qu'en moyenne je paye
2000 euros par mois
on fait pas on fait quoi quand j'écoute
Bruno Le Maire et et la ministre parlait
en fait je pense qu'ils sont hors sol
je respecte parce que Elisabeth bande a
dit il y aura des reports mais les
retours on va nous reporter quoi mais
comment tu vas faire au bout d'un moment
faut payer sinon tu vas te retrouver
avec 20000 plus les 20000 en plus
on veut pas on veut pas d'aide on veut
juste payer ce qu'on doit payer une
petite augmentation par rapport à
l'Ukraine ce qui se passe on l'entend on
comprend les 15 %. on a un PGE à
remboursé je pense que tout ce qui va se
passer après c'est que non mais déjà le
bilan moi on pourra pas rembourser les
PG aussi on dépose donc tous les
milliards qu'ils auront mis sur la table
tout va être perdu le personnel le
personnel qui va être au chômage ça va
aller très vite ça va être l'économie
française qui va être par terre non mais
parce que là on parle de tout
l'artisanat on parle des entreprises
quand vous voyez je crois il y a Duralex
qui a fermé il y a quelques mois sur sur
le truc parce qu'il pouvait pas payer
ils sont passés
il y a mois de janvier
exactement
que les boulanger c'est c'est c'est tous
les artisans tous ceux qui sont sur le
fameux tarif jaune on est foutu ouais
Stéphane comment vous allez faire là
vous faites quoi là en fait moi j'ai pas
en janvier 19000 faites comment non j'ai
bloqué j'ai bloqué le prélèvement j'ai
demandé un échéancier j'ai été sympa ils
m'ont dit on vous le fait en quatre mois
en échéancier de 4 mois après ils ont
ils m'ont rappelé ils m'ont dit ok on va
vous faire six mois j'ai la Tannée pour
les avoir déjà et quand il vous
répondent c'est toujours à côté donc ils
disent pas tous les deux avions vous
allez devoir le donner donc un moment
comment ça va s'accumuler beaucoup de
février un moment vous allez faire
comment non bah on va pas faire on va
pas faire déjà on va pas on va pas on va
pas être prélevé moi je vais faire des
petits virements pour montrer que je
suis pas de mauvaise foi et je vais
payer plus que ce que je paye en temps
normal pour l'instant voilà non j'ai
donné j'ai donné 4000 là je vais refaire
un petit virement de 4000 ainsi de suite
je pourrai pas payer je sais pas en
mesure de payer de tel montant aussi ça
fait 23 ans c'est une affaire familiale
ouais c'était mon père c'est un travail
de d'année en année c'est une affaire
familiale il y a mes sœurs dedans et on
va tout perdre je fais travailler ma
petite sœur qui est handicapée demain si
on perd ça on perd tout c'est à dire que
il y a nous mais il y a mes salariés et
encore une fois on parle pas que nous
hein c'est incroyable je pense que le
gouvernement il se rend pas compte de ce
qui va se passer ils ont pas compte les
trains de SICAV on leur dit que nous on
a des c'est quand on fait du de la
nourriture quand on fait à manger comme
artisan attention on parle pas de
micro-ondes ou j'allume et ça fait Billy
Billy quand ça fait c'est de la viande
Bala balaf casser du poisson on parle de
fraises artisans qui se lèvent le matin
qui vont chercher leurs légumes frais
qui travaillent à des producteurs locaux
avec la Chambre d'Agriculture et cetera
les gens qui vont chercher leurs
produits qui travaillent mais eux ils
ont besoin énergétiques on les appelle
monsieur Macron j'appelle madame borne
j'appelle j'appelle tout Monsieur le
Maire et Madame Grégoire regardez dans
leur cuisine allez parler taper à la
porte de leur cuisine allez lisez allez
voir leur chef leur demander s'ils ont
plus de 36 kg
s'il faut un repas de 20 personnes
simplement combien il leur faut de
puissance énergétiques pour faire à
manger pour 20 personnes en fait ils
n'ont pas pris la mesure de ce qui va se
passer parce que ce qui va se passer là
ça va être tout le monde dans la rue je
n'ai jamais fait de manifestation de ma
vie je suis pas je suis pas contre les
manifestations mais là je vais y aller
et j'ai pas de limite il y a les courses
samedi et toutes les manipulations qui
vont se présenter j'y serai j'y serai là
c'est toute notre vie je pense à tous
les boulangers à tous les artisans qui
nous regardent c'est on ne peut pas s'en
sortir c'est impossible c'est simple
mais qu'est-ce qu'on vous dit
aujourd'hui
quels sont les solutions parce que
est-ce qu'on vous est-ce qu'il va y
avoir des solutions parce que chaque
jour qui passe vous rapproche du du
drame on produit on produit le mégawatt
en France à 42 euros on nous le revend à
800000 euros ou à un moment qui se gave
je pose la question qui se gave mais on
veut bien faire des efforts parce que il
y a la guerre en Ukraine parce qu'il y a
des centrales qui n'ont pas été voilà
alimenté aujourd'hui le prix du gaz il
est tombé en dessous
et ça mais il faut aussi que les efforts
soient des deux côtés en vrai parce que
aujourd'hui reporter reporté
l'opportunité des paiements
vous allez vous retrouver en juin à
payer tout ça c'est impossible parce que
c'est ce que m'a proposé on peut pas
citer les fournisseurs mais c'est ce que
ma proposé mon fournisseur donc il m'a
proposé 4 mois et le gouvernement nous
propose aussi des détails
et au bout d'un moment non mais moi j'ai
une chose on veut bien aider tout le
monde on veut bien aider bien sûr on est
pour aider les
ukrainiens et des tout le monde mais un
moment il faut qu'à un moment le
gouvernement aide les Français et à un
moment les Francis sont prêtés les
autres pays mais à un moment si eux se
retrouvent étrangler c'est ça qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a des déclarations de
gens qui disent nous on aimerait bien
être aidé avant peut-être les autres
pays c'est ce qu'on entend siniquement
quel est l'intérêt du gouvernement de
Macron de faire crever les restaurateurs
ils peuvent pas aider maman à un moment
j'ai raté
il faut seulement Géraldine le problème
que tu as et je te le dis c'est que tu
peux pas aider tout le monde à un moment
un moment tu dois faire des choix en
fait
je suis tout à fait d'accord combien
coûterait le bouclier tarifaire pour
au-dessus
est-ce qu'ils peuvent le faire qu'est-ce
qu'ils peuvent causer tant de milliards
à l'Ukraine est-ce qu'ils peuvent donner
de milliards 3 millions
pour pour remettre en place les
décentrales nucléaires à un moment
comment ils font le problème il est là
tu as raison on a l'impression que hier
soir aussi
oui
bien sûr
l'État peut dire à Total et j'avais déjà
dit quand tu as vu la grève de l'essence
l'État peut dire à Total aussi bien sûr
ça 2 euros vous faites des milliards sur
le dos des Français qui vous gavez avec
votre essence vous pouvez aussi dire à
Total maintenant total on va baisser on
va calmer le jeu 19000 €, c'est pas
possible pour personne ni pour le
boulanger
l'Ukraine elle va faire froid vous allez
voir c'est à cause du froid faire ce
degrés il a jamais fait aussi chaud au
mois de décembre ma télé 2 minutes et il
est 19000 €, c'est total énergie qui
gagne des milliards de bénéfices au CAC
40 qui déclare pas tout son impôt qui
doit un moment donné aider aussi nous on
veut bien les mettre 2 € le lit comme
des cons mais il faut aussi des mecs là
sinon
et pas le détail alors donc c'est des
j'aimerais qu'on vienne euh sur sur
Stéphane donc Stéphane vous vous avez un
restaurant depuis combien de temps le le
carré ça fait mon père mon père était à
l'origine donc ça fait 23 ans et ensuite
j'ai tenu ça avec mes sœurs donc ça fait
ça fait 23 ans qu'on est là quand vous
avez dit Adrien lui il a vu le le truc
arriver il a fermé en janvier
vous qu'est-ce qui s'est passé j'ai été
naïf parce que je pensais que je pensais
qu'il allait avoir une augmentation mais
je m'attendais pas à ça en fait je
pensais que ça allait on allait avoir un
petit 10%
15%, et à limite je leur ai accepté mais
là c'est c'est pour moi c'est de la
science-fiction c'était pas possible
quand j'ai reçu j'ai été prélevé 10000
euros le jour du de Noël je me suis dit
bon ça doit être une régulation je vais
je suis avec eux je vais voir ensuite je
reçois un autre mail prochaine facture
19500 euros là j'étais livide quand vous
recevez ça vous dites pas à moi
je suis foutu où il y a un malentendu
ouais je me suis dit c'est pas possible
et je suis pas je suis pas comme mon
frère je suis pas je suis pas dans les
syndicats j'étais pas au au temps
présent dans dans l'actualité que
Monsieur donc du coup je me suis fait un
petit peu surprendre on va dire si vous
avez
la voix démontée
vous avez besoin de tu sais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Mathieu on a deux mecs désespérés à côté
de toi et toi tu t'en vas en disant j'ai
besoin de sucer
très discrète
Adrien il adore rigoler en plus hein on
a tellement rigolé ensemble mais c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui vous voulez
absolument vous avoir parce que il faut
absolument que ça bouge très très vite
samedi il va avoir plein de gens dans la
rue vous comme vous l'avez dit première
fois que vous allez manifester ouais j'y
serai et puis je sais pas ce qui va se
passer et je pense que ça va prendre
beaucoup beaucoup d'ampleur parce que là
d'un coup d'ampleur est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui je le dis chaque jour qui
passe chaque jour qui passe fait que des
gens se disent demain je vais pas
pouvoir ouvrir et des milliers de choses
à chaque mois qui passe quand il reçoit
les factures et combien un boulanger je
faisais le calcul tout à l'heure vous
rendez compte quand un boulanger à 20000
euros de facture d'électricité combien
de baguettes ils doivent vendre
baguette pour payer ton électricité
de chiffre d'affaires tu dois vendre
20000 dans le mois et t'as pas pris 1 €
tu fais le calcul tu dis c'est
impossible comment tu fais 20 000
baguettes dans le mois tu en as combien
c'est mort comment tu tu vas perdre tous
les mois 10 15000 € et je préviens je
rappelle en plus Cyril que les gens
remboursent tous sur 3 ans en ce moment
les prêts à garantis de l'État les
fameux PGA ça peut être très cher parce
que je vous le remboursez aussi on est
obligé de rembourser et ce qu'il a dit
oui voilà ils estiment que 30 % ne
seront jamais remboursé en France mais
cumuler cumulé aujourd'hui c'est
impossible non mais je vous dis là là il
faut faire quelque chose très très vite
qu'est-ce que vous attendez Stéphane et
Adrien nous l'avait dit c'est le
bouclier mais c'est le bouclier il
faudrait alors le bouclier pour
expliquer à noter les spectateurs
qu'est-ce que c'est en fait le bouclier
le bouclier tarifaire c'est très simple
aujourd'hui le particulier protégé avec
une hausse maximale de 15% sur un sur un
compteur bleu qu'on a tous à la maison
de qui va jusqu'à 36 kVA nous
professionnel on a souvent des compteurs
jaunes puisqu'on est plus demandeurs
d'énergie donc c'est les compteurs du
jaune
voilà et plus pour après pour ceux qui
ont des plus gros compteurs et nous on
est on a aucun bouclier tarifaire donc
on a qu'un amortisseur donc ça peut
s'envoler ça explose exactement donc il
peut avoir des mecs qui peuvent se
retrouver avec une carte de voiture de
80 000 par mois on a eu des 60000 c'est
ça comment on fait on sait pas c'est
pourquoi qu'est-ce qui vous répondent à
ça mais là on nous répond on fait vous
avez des gens des gens qui qui vous
répondent mais qui répondent à côté et
qui n'ont pas et ils vous disent c'est
pas négociable ils le disent comme ça
c'est pas négociable et vous serez
prélevé à telle date on peut négocier
sur quatre mois au départ ils m'ont dit
4 mois après ils ont été sympa ils m'ont
dit 6 mois
ça leur coûte à eux quand ça vous coûte
20000 il se gave mais 42 €. tu l'as
acheté le gouvernement actuellement je
le dis moi je veux bien aider tout le
monde il y a pas de problème mais à un
moment tu dis au gars
et ben les mec vous allez pas faire ni
faut à deux ni x 3 ni X4 vous allez
faire pour l'instant
tu vas faire au prix non mais sérieux
tu fais au prix coûtant rien on essaie
on veut aider tout le monde et bah si on
veut aider tout le monde et ben allons
jusqu'au bout un moment tu sais quoi toi
aussi tu vas te serrer la bise tu fais
juste pour payer tes salariés donc au
prix coûtant pour que tout est salarié
soit payé pour que mais à un moment si
tu veux me gaver en plus en période où
on doit aider tout le monde et que tu as
des mecs qui se retrouvent à la rue
j'ai eu écoute fournisseur d'électricité
qui ont appelé leurs clients en leur
disant quittez-nous partez parce que ça
sera pas possible donc moi j'aurais aimé
qu'on me dit ça total ils sont venus me
voir ils m'ont sollicité un commercial
est venu
les mecs c'est très simple moi le
gouvernement doit dire un moment c'est
c'est aussi le rôle du mecs stop je vous
le dis on est quoi là 2023 et ben de
janvier à juin
terminé voilà vous allez faire 6 mois
vous allez faire au prix coûtant vous
êtes gavé de façon voilà c'est très bien
et moi je suis très content que les gens
gagnent de l'argent comme je le dis je
suis très content mais un moment quand
on sait faire la liste
on sait pas ce qu'on a eu des lucrènes
et parce qu'on a pas remis les centrales
en activité que tu as des gars des
boulangers des des mecs qui sont des
artisans qui vont se retrouver à la rue
parce que c'est un coup de quoi c'est un
coup de six mois en vrai de 6 mois 6
mois et bah il faut tout ce qu'on soit
ensemble qu'on soit et qu'on se dise on
va tous faire des efforts dans le même
sens un moment les mecs je vous lis si
nous regardent se porte bien
il passe un coup de fil il dit c'est
comme ça les mecs il y a pas à discuter
on vous a donné
ils se rendent pas compte qu'ils sont en
train de se tirer une balle dans le pied
les petits les artisans et tout
représente la moitié de la puissance des
entreprises
financière française
est-ce que je dis une énorme connerie ou
est-ce que c'est faisable
tout à fait faisable non mais
franchement je je me dis c'est mais
aussi nous mettre le bouclier
faire un effort moi il y a des boules ne
croyez pas et je te le dis je comprends
rien à ce que tu dis moi quand je vois
des boulangers il y a un an ou deux ans
les boulangers roulaient pas sur l'or et
pauvre il y a des mecs des petits
artisans des mecs ils arrivaient juste à
survivre là tu leur rajoute en plus une
facture d'électricité x 10 tu veux
comment il fait les mecs c'est je peux
plus leur demander d'effort on leur a
demandé assez d'efforts à tous ces
gens-là ça suffit les efforts c'est aux
autres c'est un moment tu gèles un
moment tu dis pendant 6 mois c'est comme
ça vous aviez 2000 € bah ça sera 2000 €
pendant 6 mois c'est tout c'est comme ça
si on a bah c'est pas de votre faute
c'est pas si c'est pas c'est c'est un
moment vous êtes tributaire d'une
politique que sur laquelle vous pouvez
rien faire aujourd'hui à un moment quand
on est tout le monde il faut avoir les
moyens après les fournisseurs d'énergie
c'est des entreprises privées et elles
sont peut-être uniquement
si l'état
moi je t'explique
c'est ce que laissez-moi demain sur une
entreprise privée comme ça voilà ils
disent bah vous voulez pas le faire et
ben je vais je vais voter noir moi tu
vas voir demain ou je vais prendre 90%
de ce que tu gagnes tu es la vérité
il a pas marché sur total par exemple
tu leur dis voilà c'est comme ça et
c'est autrement c'est comme ça il est
très très vite là on a même pas on n'a
rien devant nous ça se joue là
j'ai eu des j'ai eu des gouvernement je
le dis cette situation elle leur fait
pas plaisir ils sont euh je vous dis
c'est un truc qui sont en galère avec ça
ils veulent agir ils veulent essayer
d'agir vite on va essayer de de
contacter des personnes voilà pour voir
si ça peut aller vite mais ça il faut
qu'à un moment taper du point sur la
table et dire les mecs stop vous êtes
gavés à un moment même c'est même pas un
c'est même pas je vous dis c'est même
pas une sanction c'est limite tu
discutes avec les gars tu leur dis voilà
est-ce que toi tu es un homme comme nous
quand tu vois des gens qui vont être à
la rue
parce que il paye quatre fois plus
d'électricité même dans ta tête de dans
ta tête de citoyens un moment tu dis pas
oui je vais faire pendant six mois et
ben je vais leur faire appris tout le
temps un moment je sais même pas une
sanction à maman c'est une discussion et
voilà regarde tu vois ce boulanger moi
je le ramène le monsieur qui était là à
la fois Stéphane je le dis voilà lui il
a fermé sa boulangerie le mot il était
passionné de boulangerie il était ici en
pleurs tu le mets devant le patron de
Total énergie tu dis voilà les mecs
comme ça tous les jours il y en a il y
en a des dizaines il s'en fout est-ce
que ça te fait plaisir ça non je peux
pas croire qu'un mec non il s'en [__]
la situation si le mec s'en fout
franchement alors là
je comprends mais moi je pense qu'il
faut mettre devant ça faut le mettre de
faire ça ils attendent d'être menacé par
le gouvernement moi j'aimerais bien
voilà si des personnes de Total énergie
ou autre nous regarde ce soir j'aimerais
beaucoup qui viennent demain
Stéphane pour y revenir ou voilà qu'on
vienne s'expliquer combien de trouver
des solutions ensemble ici parce que on
les a appelé pour l'instant pas eu de
réponse nous on laisse la parole à tout
le monde on les écoutera il y aura pas
on sera pas là pour pour les engueuler
pour voilà pour on sera là pour discuter
essayer de trouver des solutions pour
qu'il nous explique pourquoi ils peuvent
pas faire ce qu'on est en train de dire
là si on peut avoir un haut responsable
ça serait top parce que qu'on avance et
parce que là je vous dis à urgence
chaque minute qui passe chaque heure qui
passe il y a des mecs et les mecs qu'on
aime et moi quand je vois des mecs en
détresse comme ça quand je vois des mecs
pleurer sur mon plateau parce qu'ils
sont ils ont une boulangerie qui est à
leur père qui est à leur grand-père et
qui sont obligés de la fermer c'est eux
qui culpabilisent parce qu'ils disent
bah tu vois l'héritage que j'ai eu de
mon père mon grand-père j'ai même pas
réussi à le conserver et quand je vois
Stéphane aujourd'hui Stéphane tu étais
au bureau ce que je disais à ma femme
avant de rentrer je pense à mon père
bien sûr tu dis quoi tu dis j'ai pas été
capable on a passé des moments très
difficiles entre les attentats quand je
dis ça c'est parce que ça nous a bloqué
dans notre activité mais comme tu dis
les gilets jaunes ça vous a bloqué dans
les activités mais comme je l'ai dit à
chaque fois
un moment ils sont au milieu de tout
alors les gilets jaunes et pas de leur
faute mais les commerçants non mais ils
peuvent pas ouvrir parce que forcément
il y a des actions à l'Ukraine on peut
pas bah c'est forcément donc on doit
aider l'Ukraine donc forcément bah là
l'électricité ça va être x 10 à un
moment les mecs c'est déjà si tout
rouler et que les mecs qui se gavaient
si vous vous gaviez voilà
connecté non mais non mais un moment
c'est il faut que ces mecs là viennent
sur le plateau je suis désolé on
aimerait beaucoup vraiment avoir ces
mecs là qu'on en parle demain s'ils
veulent venir demain après-demain demain
ce serait pas voilà qu'on en parle qu'on
avance chaque jour qui passe et qui nous
fasse au moins une réponse qui nous
disent pourquoi pourquoi aujourd'hui
c'est pas possible de faire ce qu'on
vient de dire c'est c'est incroyable
tous les gens qui nous regardent la joie
il y a énormément de réaction
Stéphane toi aujourd'hui tu te laisses
combien de temps pas longtemps c'était
longtemps parce que je vais je vais je
vais tenir en échelonnant mais je ne
sais pas à quoi m'attendre la prochaine
facture je sais pas
je peux pas payer ça c'est je tiendrai
pas tu perds de l'argent tous les mois
on perds de l'argent tu perds de trésor
vous pouvez tenir combien avant de
fermer l'association totalement la
boulangerie
de moi c'est fermé
tu crois deux mois j'ai dit faut que ça
aille très vite les mecs les
restaurateurs les gars oh ils ont été
fermés pendant des années des mois ils
ont eu le confinement ils ont eu mais un
moment tu te dis que c'est pas possible
c'est pour ça que j'en appelle un peu au
bon sens à la citoyenneté du dégât des
des dirigeants de ces sociétés à un
moment tu dis moi ça leur fait ça doit
leur faire de la peine quand ils vont
aller à leur boulangerie le matin parce
que le mec il est comme nous il va à la
boulangerie le matin
je suis comme un con tu vois non mais
c'est vrai c'est pour ça touche tout le
monde c'est pour ça que je t'aime moi
c'est pour ça que je t'aime parce que
parce que tu es trop généreux tu es trop
bien tu aimes bien ce qui est ce qui est
fou c'est c'est dingue ce qui leur
arrive mais ce qui leur arrive là c'est
toute la France c'est quand j'ai dit
engueuler en disant oui tu veux pas me
soutenir l'Ukraine moi je veux bien me
soutenir le crâne ça coûte de l'argent
de soutenir le crâne combien de temps la
guerre elle va durer combien de temps
parce que l'essence c'est cher
tu n'as pas quelle heure les gens qui
sont en arrière on les voit pas Marine
Le Pen vous savez arrête arrête arrête
arrête on parle de y a des gens allez
voir il y en a des courses
est-ce que pour vous ça avoir ou pas
bien sûr
que ça va avoir envie
c'est pas l'Ukraine c'est la Russie
alors parfois
non mais Géraldine ce que veut dire
l'ukrainement
c'est comme quand tu vas dans un
restaurant et que tu dis je vais offrir
à tout le monde c'est ma tournée mais tu
peux pas payer ta table
momentne vous pensez vraiment que nous
on n'aura pas de problème de gaz on aura
une électricité c'est pas du tout
je comprends rien de ce qu'il veut dire
mais non mais c'est vrai tu peux lui
répondre
14 €
j'ai mis 138 € d'essence c'est démago
c'est ma faute c'est moi c'est moi tout
ça c'est moi les les restaurants mais tu
as raison marche c'est ma faute tout est
de ma faute moi j'ai dit ici je vais je
suis d'accord avec moi je vois mes
dépenses moi et j'ai de la chance une
fois de plus d'être ici j'ai un une
énorme chance et je vois mon entourage
autour de moi qui me parle et qui me dit
bah ça on devait le faire on le fait
plus ça on devait le faire on le fait
plus pourquoi parce que parce qu'on leur
dit que c'est du crâne on a acheté de
l'électricité moins cher maintenant
parce qu'on a fermé des centrales ou pas
ce qu'on a mal on a mal géré aujourd'hui
on dit que l'électricité on le paye plus
cher et je vois des 19000 € de facture
moi sur des gens de gros il a diminué
aujourd'hui tu peux pas dire que c'est
pas la Russie l'Ukraine arrête en résumé
on est sur un tonneau de dynamite il
reste plus que 2 cm de mèche c'est pour
ça qu'ils arrêtent pas de me dire c'est
pas demain ou après-demain c'est
maintenant on va finir dans la rue on va
faire quelque chose se couper la mèche
parce que ça va péter à la gueule tout
le monde aujourd'hui Adrien donc toi si
vous nous rejoignez Adrien il a un
restaurant à jeun tu as fermé pour le
mois de janvier qu'est-ce que tu fais
quoi avec tes enfants
chômage moi je partais et sur le et
j'attends tant que j'ai pas tant que
j'ai pas quelque chose de viable
d'électricité
on laisse les fournisseurs d'énergie
mais quand on va briser des familles
exactement des licenciements et parce
qu'ils seront au chômage et qui seront
au chômage deux trois voire plus et
qu'après ils auront des aides parce
qu'ils auront ils arriveront pas se
reclasser qui c'est qui va payer total
quoi le Président il avait dit quoi
qu'il en coûte moi j'aimerais bien qu'à
un moment donné ils disent quoi qu'il en
coûte maintenant je dis pas qu'il faut
taper sur les Français il faut taper sur
les gens qui se gave c'est ça et à un
moment donné il y a des gens qui se
garent au gars à ces gars là faut leur
dire les gars oh on a dit là on veut on
est de l'Ukraine les gars vous allez pas
vous gaver pendant que il y a des mecs
qui sont qui sont qui qui qui leur reste
quand tu dis deux mois les mecs vous
rendez compte ils sont c'est un compte à
rebours pour vous un compte à rebours
parce que Adrien qu'est-ce qui se passe
toi tu vas fermer à moi au mois de
janvier qu'est-ce qui va te dire que ça
va aller mieux au mois de février
dépense euh loyer assurance etc si c'est
si on a pas de de tarif viable pour le
mois de février ben c'est rebelote c'est
encore fermeture et puis voilà et si ça
baisse pas comme il disait la 2 3 mois
terminée mais c'est possible
deux ans trois ans quatre ans on fait
quoi on continue à fonctionner les gens
comme ça non mais pas durer
qu'on comprenne aujourd'hui toi toi
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de dire ta
batterie elle est de combien d'autonomie
tu peux tu peux vivre encore combien de
temps comme ça
tu fermes le restaurant de moi je ferme
le resto j'ai prévenu les salariés je
leur ai expliqué donc tout le monde sait
que c'est très compliqué et on va
peut-être pas tenir donc ils ont vu les
factures je leur on est on est très très
proche on leur montre pas on fait des
journées qui a 80000 euros qui a
travaillé toute sa vie qui a gardé 80
qui ont fermé au 31 décembre il nous
souhaite pas continuer ils font une
cessation d'activité ils arrêtent ils
préfèrent perdre leur fonds de commerce
ils arrêtent leur structure comme le vol
et pour papa l'argent qu'ils ont
économisé depuis 20 ans voilà non mais
ça va tomber j'ai raté pour revenir à ce
que tu disais c'est pas Raymond il
disait pas qu'il veut pas aider
l'Ukraine il dit qu'à un moment tout le
monde
ne cherche pas le bouc émissaire il
cherche il cherche les cours
d'Europe il cherche les causes mais toi
toi qu'est-ce que tu dis qu'est-ce que
tu dis c'est personne là qu'est-ce que
tu dis de Adrien
qui va se retrouver à la rue
qu'est-ce que tu dis du boulanger de la
musique c'est dramatique donc on dit
quoi et ben je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
France a les moyens de vous attendez mes
réponses allez moyen d'aider tout le
monde mais absolument pas le choix la
France la France
du livre s'il te plaît laisse-moi parler
avec toi la question je t'explique la
France donc forcément si la France
je suis plus d'accord avec Raymond
qu'avec moi si la France peut aider tout
le monde la France doit et le
gouvernement doit taper du pont sur la
table et dire aux gars
les mecs on a de l'Ukraine en ce moment
c'est terminé c'est zéro euro de
bénéfice c'est vous payez vos salariés
vous faites vos trucs vous êtes à 0 donc
pour l'instant
on a soutenu
j'avais misé sur le gaz important Cyril
l'économie allemande a basé sur
l'économie sur le gaz pas sur le
nucléaire et on demande à la France
aujourd'hui pour que les entreprises
allemande soit compétitive c'est ça je
rappelle que l'Allemagne a un bouclier
tarifaire exactement
la France d'augmenter son tarif
électrique parce que nous on le produit
à 42 €, on le demande pour que les
entreprises allemandes soient
concurrentielles pourquoi l'Espagne il
soit 85 € parce qu'ils sont partis
exactement le Portugal ils sont dans la
merde et maintenant on doit non on doit
aider tout le monde
tu peux pas aider tout le monde
exactement
il sait très bien l'écologie mais ils
ont voulu être à fond 100% écologique et
bah aujourd'hui il nous demande de les
aider à un moment tu as de l'Allemagne
tu as de l'Ukraine mais à un moment tu
crois quoi déjà on dirait que nous la
France on dirait qu'on est on prospère
et les mecs arrêtés
en Europe
les Français les Français ils veulent
qu'on pense d'abord
oui Géraldine on peut pas on veut aider
l'Ukraine mais il faut dire au mec de
l'énergie
et voir des paniers de notre économie
Face à Nous entrer en faillite non mais
à un moment il faut rétablir l'équilibre
et ça veut dire quoi
il faut absolument les fournisseurs
d'énergie en plus vous l'avez dit à
demi-mots ils ont une petite tendance
potentielle à spéculer sur le prix de
l'énergie c'est ça
les fournisseurs d'énergie en ce moment
qui sont responsables sur le dos des
commerces ils font leur beurre et ils
gagnent voilà donc là il faut qu'ils
arrêtent tout ça et puis au bout d'un
moment il faut rétablir les équilibres
le quoi qu'il en coûte c'était pendant
le covid il faut refaire peut-être un
quoi qu'il en coûte pendant l'Ukraine
mais on peut pas laisser mais est-ce que
il y a boulanger restaurateur puis tous
les autres aussi les bouchers les
bouchers avec le froid la chaîne du
froid la chaîne du chaud
qui garde un échameaux froides et
immense comment ils font pour payer ils
ont 120000 à 132000 par mois donc là je
suis prête à payer plus d'impôts pour
vous aider
humanitaire en Ukraine qui m'envoie un
sms qui me dit tu sais à quel point
l'Ukraine me tient à cœur il fait de
l'humanité en Ukraine il est prévenu ici
sur le plateau nous nous sommes
impliqués et que à quel point Sonic
emily-frère qu'il y a une
urgence en France et son idée nous ne
pourrons pas aider les autres il a
raison un moment non mais un moment à un
moment les gars il faut dire STOP tous
les jours qui passent eux ils perdent
des milliers d'euros
fournisseur d'énergie c'est à eux qu'il
faut tomber il faut sortir
un moment faut arrêter ça euh je vous
dis non mais pas d'argent Géraldine on
demande juste à ce qu'on a fait tout
bloqué à un moment tu sais ce qu'il faut
faire tu sais c'est comme dans une liste
de courses tu as des priorités et tu as
des trucs qu'il faut acheter en premier
et je te dis et un moment tu peux pas
mettre partout et et et et être et être
partout et te dire voilà c'est un moment
tu dois faire des choix et chose à faire
des priorités et te dire quelle est la
priorité du moment et si et si tu es et
si tu es d’abord la France tu pourras
aider tous les autres parce qu'à un
moment il faut que l'argent crève
tellement de faim aujourd'hui ça va se
terminer pas ou quelque chose
de faim on n'a pas vu ça c'est par le
pain qui a commencé la révolution 809
exactement
sur le débat soit il sera avec nous
demain Lucien vrai héros et c'est énorme
on veut les chéris dernière chose
vraiment on voudrait demain avoir un
fournisseur d'énergie voilà ou quelqu'un
voilà un responsable parce que c'est
hyper important merci Marco d'avoir été
là je sais que tu es très touché pas moi
j'aurais fait autrement
je veux pas descendre dans la rue mais
j'aurais dit c'est pas l'état que je
touchais là mais si total il m'emmerde
et énergies m'emmerde je fais une
doublette de 5 sociétés dans le
restaurant et tous les mois je dégage la
société et je me mets pas en tête et mon
électricité est là c'est tout merci
beaucoup